en 1944 la France se libère de 4 longues
années
d'occupation les résistant sont devenus
les héros d'une nouvelle page de
l'histoire de
[Musique]
France au fil des années des décennies
la mémoire collective simplifiera
etématisera les engagements d'hommes et
de femmes pris dans les tourments d'une
époque ambigue et
ince ainsi la résistance restera
invariablement associé à la gauche alors
que l'extrême droite sera synonyme de
collaboration mais l'histoire est
complexe un nouvel éclairage doit être
apporté sur cette
période il est clair que la
participation de l'extrême droite à la
résistance a été un peu masquée a été un
peu oubliée résistance dans le cas
français était une résistance qui a
unifié des gens qui venaient de
l'extrême gauche et il y avait aussi
l'extrême ro ils y
[Musique]
étaient ils vont rallier plus ou moins
de Gaulle ils seront plus facil à
rallier girud par exemple à un certain
moment et puis certains vont évoluer
vers la démocratie parce que les êtres
humains ça
[Musique]
évolue
l'idée qu'il y avait des bons qui sont
restés bons tout au long de leur trajet
et des méchants qui sont restés méchants
tout au long de leur trajet c'est une
idée qui est beaucoup plus facile à
transmettre que l'idée de complexité de
chemin et d'itinéraire
[Musique]
croissant impossible de comprendre
l'engagement et le parcours de nombreux
militants d'extrême droite dans la
résistance sans comprendre ce qu'est
l'extrême droite française et ce que vit
la France dans l'entre de
guerre l'extrême droite n'est pas un
phénomène nouveau dans la France de
l'entre de guerre vous avez eu dès la
naissance de la 3e république et
jusqu'en 1914 des ligues qui incarnaient
cette extrême droite et ces ligues
d'extrême droite ont continué à
prospérer durant l'entre de guerre on
peut penser par exemple à la Ligue des
Patriotes on peut penser également aux
Jeunesses patriotes de é qui quelque
part ont à voir avec les ligues qui
existaient avant
1914 ces ligues nationalistes prennent
le essort sur la crise de régime de la
3e
république cette 3è République pour
laquelle tant de combattants de 1418 se
sont sacrifiés est miné par de nombreux
scandales
politico-financiers de plus affaibli par
la stérilité des débats parlementaires
et la valce des ministres elle se révèle
impuissante à juguler les effets de la
crise économique apparu aux États-Unis
et qui ravage l'Europe en
[Applaudissements]
1931 c'est sur ce déclin moral social et
politique de la société française que
prospère l'extrême droite dans l'entre
de
guerre on a toujours d'ailleurs du point
de vue idéologique un peu les mêmes
thèmes l'idée d'abord que la 3è
républque
est illégitime que c'est un mauvais
parti ce qui veut dire que
l'antiparlementarisme est un élément
fédérateur d'autres éléments
interviennent également on peut songer
ici à la xénophobie à
l'antisémitisme à l'anticommunisme bien
entendu et ces éléments varient selon
selon les types de parti selon les types
de
[Applaudissements]
mouvements
[Musique]
l'un des plus importants mouvements de
cette extrême droite est l'action
française
[Musique]
emmené par un trium vira sa figure
charismatique est Charles
Moras l'Action française est un
mouvement royaliste et réactionnaire qui
n'a jamais accepté les porté par la
Révolution
française exerçant une grande séduction
intellectuelle au-delà même de son
propre camp cette droite avant tout
contre révolutionnaire souhaite
renverser la République au profit d'une
restauration monarchique et appelle de
ses vœux un antisémitisme
d'État l'antisémitisme de l'Action
française est un antisémitisme non
racial c'est un antisémitisme qui admet
l'existence de bons Juifs très limité
quant à leur nombre est très précisément
défini quant à leur leur activité donc
c'est pas un antisémitisme de type
absolu si vous voulez c'est un
antisémitisme de type discriminatoire
c'est pas un antisémitisme de type
exterminateur si vous voulez faire la
différence entre l'antisémitisme
morassien et et l'antisémitisme
hitlerrien Charles Moras par disons son
charisme ou par sa plume a véritablement
influencé une génération même si tout le
monde ne se retrouve pas dans les thèmes
de l'Action française à commencé par
l'idée d'une monarchie puisque
est monarchiste ce que n'est pas le
colonel de
laaroc le colonel de laaroc est devenu
en 1932 le chef des croix defeu un
puissant mouvement constitué d'anciens
combattants rassemblant ceux qui se sont
distingués au cours de la Grande Guerre
à la fin des années 30 laaroc transforme
ses Croix de Feu en un parti politique
de masse le PSF Parti social français
qui rassemble près de 1 million
d'adhérents sous ses aspects
autoritaires et son culte du chef le
parti n reste pas moins égaliste et
réfractaire à l'antisémitisme ce qui le
différencie de l'extrême droite
traditionnelle ce qu'il ne faut pas
oublier c'est que l'extrême droite de de
cette période est obsédée par le danger
allemand et donc si vous lisez les
parutions de l'extrême droite ou si vous
lisez bien entendu l'Action française
mais aussi d'autres d'autres publication
il y a une espèce d'obsession de ce qui
se passe en
Allemagne hanté par les possibilité de
voir un jour le vieil ennemi se réarmer
contre la France l'Action française
prône à longueur d'article une vigilance
absolue à l'égard de ce qu'elle appelle
l'Allemagne
éternelle Moras et ceux qu'il suivent
ont compris que dans la conjoncture de
la fin du 19e siècle et du début du 20e
siècle il y a une opposition
structurelle fondamentale entre la
France et l'Allemagne et qu'on aura beau
faire on aura beau dire la paix la paix
ça ira pas parce que l'Allemagne est
plus puissante que la France
démographiquement et économiquement
l'Allemagne aspire à l'hégémonie sur le
continent européen et le pays qui bloque
cette hégémonie c'est la
France en 1933 le parti nazi arrive au
pouvoir pourtant l'ensemble de la classe
politique française traditionnelle
aveuglé par un fort courant pacifiste ne
cesse de prner le désarmement face à
l'Allemagne qui elle reconstitue sa
puissance militaire avec
Hitler
[Musique]
Moras va employer une expression qui est
une expression très juste il va dire que
le nazisme est en fait un multiplicateur
du germanisme c'est-à-dire que Hitler au
pouvoir va donner au germanisme la
possibilité de de de d'abord de de se
reconstituer comme puissance et de
détruire le traité de versaill bien
entendu et en plus de menacer la France
donc si on regarde l'extrême droite
française de 33 à 36 disons elle est
obsédée par le danger allemand et elle
accuse la gauche française d'être trop
magnanime d'être trop sympathique de
trop indulgente à l'égard de l'Allemagne
à l'égard de l'Allemagne avant la montée
des nazis mais même après la montée des
nazis au
pouvoir en France un nouveau scandale
politicofinancier éclate en janvier 1934
l'affaire Staviski qui éclabousse une
partie du personnel républicain suscite
la colère de nombreux
Français profite de la crise pour
appeler à se rassembler dans Paris au CR
de abat les
voleurs le 6 février 1934 date marquante
dans l'histoire de cette extrême droite
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
manifestent dans la capitale contre le
régime
[Musique]
parlementaire lorsqu'à 19h un coup de
feu venu d'on sais où retentit la
manifestation dégénère la police la
répression est sanglante 14 morts et
plus de 600
blessés
dans cette foule des metiers se trouve
un futur grand résistant Gilbert Renaud
qui se fera connaître sous le nom de
colonel réy fervant catholique ce
producteur de cinéma est un monarchiste
convaincu qui n'hésite pas à affronter
les forces de l'ordre le soir du 6
février au cours de cette nuit agitée
les éléments les plus extrêmes espèrent
renverser la République mais le coup de
force tant espéré échoue en Rost les
Parti de Gauche se mobilise ce qui
conduira à l'avèement du Front populaire
2 ans plus tard cet événement va
important pour l'extrême droite parce
que pour l'extrême droite qui va qui va
grossir qui va elle va être extrêmement
importante aussi pour pour la gauche qui
va brandir non sans raison le risque
d'une menace contre contre la République
et contre et contre la démocratie et
donc il va avoir une rupture dans l'état
dans l'histoire de France ce 6 février
34 quelques jours après le 6 février
l'extrême droite enterre ses martyres
parmi les ligueurs de l'Action française
beaucoup critiqu la tièur des chefs et
quitent le
mouvement c'est le cas de pierre de
benénouville ce jeune homme n peine plus
de 20 ans étudiant en lettrre et de
toutes les bagarres au Quartier Latin
d'une énergie presque animale ce dure à
force d'hurler dans les manifestations
finit par se casser la
voix d'autres dissidents forment au
milieu des années 30 ce qui devient une
organisation terroriste et que les chefs
d'Action française surnomment avec
mépris la cagoule
la cagoule a été une organisation
secrète qui a fait de l'antiommunisme sa
marque de fabrique et donc l'idée était
que la République était en grand danger
car elle était subvertie par les
communistes et donc cette cagoule s'est
distingué en montant des opérations
secrètes des attentats qu'elle
attribuait aux communistes pour mieux
déclencher la répression contre les
communistes comploteurs conspirateurs
vivant dans le culte du secret les
membres de la cagoule perpètrent de
nombreux attentats et assassinats
jusqu'à la fin des années
30 l'organisation trouve des appuis dans
les plus hautes sphères de la finance et
des milieux militaires les entreprises
Michelin L'Oréal les HES leciieur
subventionnent l'organisation
secrète démantelé en 1938 ses principaux
responsables sont arrêtés
sous l'Occupation les membres de la
cagoule se diviseront si beaucoup
verseront dans la collaboration d'autres
feront le choix inverse et choisiront la
résistance c'est le cas du chef du
trafic d'armes de la cagoule Maurice du
Clos courtier en assurance ce géant
sympathique etpris d'action ralliera la
France libre du général de Gaulle dès
juin
1940 en mai 1940 l'Allemagne envahit la
France des hordes de chars desferles sur
les
routes l'armée affaiblie par
l'impréparation militaire ne peut
résister au rouleau compresseur
nazi partout c'est la
débacle cette défaite la France ne s'en
est jamais complètement remise elle
choque le monde entier et traumatisent
profondément les
Français toutes les forces politiques de
droite comme de gauche sont sur le
moment anéanti et ne savent pas comment
réagir face à cet
événement l'extrême droite a été très
divisé par la défaite de 1940 d'une part
elle n'aime pas l'Allemagne la défaite
ne la réjouit pas de l'autre la défaite
est aussi considérée dans une certaine
mesure comme la sanction d'une décadence
française comme la preuve vivante au
fond que cette république a été
incapable d'assumer la défense du
pays en juin 1940 les Français remettent
leur destin dans les mains du maréchal
Pétin âgé de 84 ans profitant de la
situation celui-ci obtient les pleins
pouvoirs pour réclamer
[Musique]
l'armistice un mois plus tard le 10
juillet à Vichi Pétin se fait proclamer
chef de l'État français la Révolution
nationale est en marche comme l'ensemble
des Français une grande partie de
l'extrême droite seraé au
maréchal la plupart de ces gens
d'extrême droite ou d'une droite
musclée
acceptte d'accompagner le destin du
maréchal mais veulent faire pression
pour que dans tous les arbitrages le
maréchal manifeste son autonomie à
l'égard de l'Allemagne c'est-à-dire
essayer d'infiltrer l'appareil d'État
profiter de cet appareil d'État pour
construire la lutte dans estim--il
l'esprit du maréchal car beaucoup sont
persuader aussi que le maréchal Pétin
finasse comme on dit joue double jeu et
donc prépare en secret la
revanche ce calcul on le retrouve chez
deux militaires proches des milieux
cagoulard avant guerre le colonel
Groussard responsable des services
secret
vistes et le chef de la Légion française
des combattants George lon
cet ancien officier d'infanterie fut
renvoyé de l'armée à la fin des années
30 parce qu'il avait créé une officine
clandestine chargée d'empêcher les
infiltrations
communistes au sein d'un groupement
appelé la spirale il publia avant guerre
des revues à caractère anti-allemand et
fortement
[Musique]
antisémite Marie-Madeleine Fourcade sa
secrétaire qui partage ses convictions
nationalistes ne le quitte pas durant
toutes ces
années Madeleine fourcalelle est une
bourgeoise de droite qui racontera dans
ses mémoires en 1900 qu'en 1936 elle
assiste dans un thé sympathique une
espèce de de de réception sympathique
elle assiste à une discussion entre
louonolaco et de Gaulle et elle entend
avec stupéfaction que l'un et l'autre
sont très pessimistes quand la
possibilité pour la France de résister à
l'Allemagne on est en 36 tout le monde
pense encore que la France est à l'armée
la plus forte d'Europe et elle entend
deux types qui sont deux types de
l'armée
et donc le lendemain elle se met en
rapport avec loun la et elle sera la
secrétaire générale des institutions que
crée louonaco notamment de la spirale
c'estàd que marie-madeline Fourcade dans
les années 38 39
publie des des un journal où il y a des
articles
antisémites au sein de Vichy
Marie-Madeleine Fourcade et louono LAAC
rêvent de former avec l'aide de
Groussard une armée de vichissois
antinazie à partir d'éléments de l'armée
d'armistice afin de préparer la
[Musique]
revanche ça c'est un exemple où c'est
une illustration du fait que pour pour
certains
nationalistes on pouvait penser que
Vichy en fait servirait de sanctuaire et
de protection à une future résistance en
cette été 1940 si certains individus
cherchent à lutter contre l'occupant
depuis la France d'autres font un tout
autre choix ils rejoignent l'Angleterre
et s'engage dans la France libre du
général de Gaulle qui a lancé son appel
à la résistance le 18
juin c'est le cas de Gilbert Renaud l'un
des hmetiers du 6 février 34 qui à
Londres prend le pseudonyme de colonel
réy réy a été horrifié par le spectacle
de la débacle et par le soulagement
général à l'annonce de l'armistice le 18
juin au matin ayant end dire que les
Allemands arriveraient à Van dans
l'après-midi ce qui d'ailleurs ne s'est
fait que de ou 3 jours plus tard j'ai
dit à ma femme si Hitler gagne cette
guerre toi et moi nous allons devenir
des esclaves et nos enfants seront
élevés dans la doctrine nationale
socialiste autrement dit leur âme sera
perdue je pense que tu es d'accord avec
moi que dans une telle hypothèse il
vaudrait mieux que nous mourrions tous
je vais essayer d'aller me battre le
réflexe qui m'a fait partir pour
l'Angleterre trouvit son origine dans
l'enseignement que depuis 20 ans je
recevais sous la signature de Charles
Moras nourri de Action française il ne
m'était pas possible de reconnaître
comme définitive la défaite de la France
expliquera-t-il plus
tard dans ces débuts de la France Libre
peu nombreux sont les hommes comme Rémi
qui se rallient au général de Gaulle en
1940 autour du général de Gaulle se
regroupe des gens qui viennent
d'horizons très différents on peut noter
une surreprésentation des juifs et des
membres de l'extrême droite la
surreprésentation des Juifs s'explique
par le fait que il ils ont beaucoup à
craindre beaucoup à redouter de
l'occupation allemande quant à l'extrême
droite pour eux pour une partie de
l'extrême droite il est clair que la
défaite de la
France est considérée comme un comme un
drame et qu'il faut réagir de manière
absolue à cette défaite ce qui va amener
euh deg lui-même à dire j'avais autour
de moi il y a plusieurs façons il y a
plusieurs expressions de cette fameuse
formule j' pr-mi des Juifs lucides et
des et des aristocrates il y a des
formules un peu plus disons vulgaires du
style j'avais avec moi la synagogue et
la cagoule enfin voyez deg lui-même
vient vient d'un milieu influencé où
lui-même personnellement a été
intellectuellement influencé par le
moracisme bien qu'il ait développé ses
propres conceptions et sa propre sa
propre logique nationaliste si vous
voulez de Gaulle qui essaie de fédérer
le maximum de volontaires est tiraill
entre sa gauche et sa droite au sein de
son propre camp certains lui reprochent
de n'être pas assez républicain alors
que d'autres lui reprochent de l'être
trop par une sorte d'ironie de
l'histoire ces hommes vont devoir uvrer
en commun pour le succès de la
[Musique]
cause loin de ses préoccupations
politiques le colonel remémy désire agir
au plus vite il rejoint alors le service
secret de la France
libre dans l'immeuble vétus de Duke
Street à Londres Remy retrouve la
première poignée d'agents secret composé
de monarchistes catholiques comme le
compte honoré d'Étienne dorve et
d'ancien cagoulard comme Maurice Duclot
l'homme du trafic d'armes de la cagoule
ce dernier connait une ascension
fulgurante dans les services secret
goiste au sein desquel il prendra la
tête de la section
action ce qui je crois va faciliter
l'entrée de ces hommes dans les services
secrets c'est que précisément il
s'engage dans des services secrets en
d'autres termes ils ne s'engag pas dans
l'armée régulière eux même si vous avez
des hommes venus de la droite extrême je
pense par exemple à Lecler et il ne
s'engage pas non plus dans ce que l'on
appellera les mouvements de
résistance ce qui veut dire que quelque
part la forme d'action qu'incarne les
service secret leur plaît et puis ce qui
joue peut-être aussi c'est une culture
politique et cette cure politique c'est
une culture politique très marquante
pour l'extrême droite c'est-à-dire une
culture politique du complot de l'action
clandestine dès l'été 1940 cette poignée
d'agents secret est parachuté en France
avec cette mission établir au plus vite
des réseaux
d'espionnage recueil et transmission de
renseignement exfiltration vers
l'Angleterre passage de la ligne de
démarcation action de sabotage sont les
premières activités de ces réseaux
l'un des gros problèmes des réseaux de
résistance c'est de transmettre les
informations qu'il recueillent et donc
il faut absolument disposer notamment de
post émetteur ou de chaînes de courrier
pour par exemple transmettre les plans
c'est la grande tâche du colonel reméi
et cette tâche il l'accomplit de manière
absolument incroyable c'est sans doute
l'agent secret le plus expérimenté de la
France
Libre le colonel Rémy crée au fil des
mois ce qui devient le plus puissant
réseau de la France Libre la confrériie
Notre-Dame ce personnage charmeur
établit ses premières zone de contact
dans les milieux moraciens qu'il connaît
bien et parvient à enrôler une foule de
civils anonym prêt à aider la résistance
[Musique]
naissante tandis que les golistes
s'affèent à créer des organisations de
résistance le régime de Vichy c'est
solidement implanté dans la station
thermale où un semblant d'État
[Musique]
réapparaît mais en coulisse des clans
s'affrontent pour influer sur la
politique du maréchal un homme tire son
épingle du jeu Pierre
Laval cet ancien ponte de la 3e
république estime que la collaboration
doit être la grande politique à laquelle
il doit attacher son
nom le 24 octobre 140 à Montoire la
politique de collaboration est scellée
entre Vichy et le 3è Reich cette poignée
de main indigne le clan anti-allemand de
Vichy pour Marie-Madeleine Fourcade
Pétin n'est désormais qu'un vieux
capitulur autour de l'hôtel du Parc des
conspirations de palais
apparaissent le 25 décembre le colonel
Groussard fait arrêter Pierre Laval avec
le consentement de Pétin qui voit d'un
mauvais œil cet ambitieux intrigant en
tout sens mais les Allemands furieux
exige sa libération qu'ils obtiennent 4
jours plus tard le clan anti-allemand
est désavoué Groussard finira par
rejoindre la résistance les dernières
personnes dont on peut dire qu'elles
étaient plus ou moins proches de
l'Action française seront seront éliminé
de Vichy après le coup le fameux coup de
décembre 1940 c'est quand on a vidé laav
et les Allemands en réplique disent ben
vous allez vider si vous avez vidé laav
maintenant vous allez vider tous ceux
qui sont
anti-allemands
Avichi les ministres se succèdent et
c'est l'amiral d'Arlan partisan lui
aussi de la collaboration qui est nommé
chef du gouvernement d'Arlan au pouvoir
les activités résistantes du clan
anti-allemand jusqu'ici officieusement
toléré prennent fin louono l qui monta
depuis plusieurs mois un réseau de
renseignement entre définitivement dans
la
[Musique]
clandestinité en contact avec les agents
secret Gaulistes ses relations avec de
Gaulle se dégradent au fil des
mois
finalement il préfèrent se rattacher
directement au service secret
britannique en avril 41 son réseau
devient alors
l'alliance l'alliance qui va être le
plus gros réseau d'espionnage qui va
travailler pour les Anglais et c'est un
réseau absolument magnifique où il y
aura un taux de perte absolument
gigantesque de perte dire ceux qui
seront pris et tués par les allemand qui
transmet aux Anglais toutes les
informations sur l'aviation allemande en
France sur les bateaux sur les les
toutes les informations militaires
nécessaires aux Anglais à faire la
guerre et à bombarder qu quand il faut
quand il faut bombarder mais louono lako
est très vite arrêté et emprisonné par
Vichy livré aux Allemands il résiste à
des dizaines d'interrogatoires et
déporté au camp de
matausen alliance n'a plus son chef et
Marie-Madeleine Fourcade se retrouve
désormais seule à la tête de ce réseau
quand elle prend la tête du réseau elle
n'ose pas dire à Londres qu'elle est une
femme parce qu'à Londres on comprend
prendrait pas qu'une femme prend la tête
d'un réseau d'espionnage et donc elle se
fait passer pour un homme c'estàd elle
elle rédige ces textes au masculin et et
non au féminin d'où la surprise des
anglais quand ils la rencontreront un
peu plus tard au Portugal et qui voit
arriver une une femme donc qui est en
fait la chef du réseau Alliance je peux
pas dire que nous étions prédestinés
nous étions très certainement
prédisposés
euh faire ce que nous avons fait parce
que nous étions un tout petit groupe de
français qui déjà bien avant la guerre
avait pensé que ilit représenter un
immense danger pour le monde et le
fondateur de notre réseau George lenac
avait 2 ans avant la guerre déjà
accumulé un très très grand nombre de
renseignements sur la puissance
militaire de
l'Allemagne au commencement de la
résistance les militants d'extrême
droite sont présents en force mais les
événements s'enchaînent la guerre prend
un nouveau tournant lorsque l'Allemagne
attaque par surprise l'Union soviétique
les communistes paralysés jusque là par
le pacte germanosoviétique peuvent
désormais agir et entrent massivement
dans la
Résistance les attentats communistes de
l'été 41 poussent les Allemands à
déclencher des
représailles la jangoliste honoré
d'Étienne dorve arrêté depuis janvier
torturé condamné à mort est exécuté avec
ses compagnons au montvérien le 29 août
comme de nombreux otages
communistes
la rose et le
rés celui qui croyait au ciel celui qui
n'y croyait pas de ador la belle
prisonnière des soldat lequ
àéchelle déclam par Louis Aragon pendant
la guerre sont dédi au monarchiste d'or
et au communiste Gabriel per il
symbolise la cruelle rencontre de ses
ennemis d'hier face au pleton
d'exécution
naz
[Musique]
en avril 42 la Val revient au pouvoir
avec le concours des
[Musique]
Allemands j'ai la volonté de rétablir
avec l'Allemagne et avec l'Italie
relation normales et
confi je souhaite la victoire de
l'Allemagne parce que sans elle le
bolchevisme demain s'installera
partout pour beaucoup de Français ce
n'est qu'au fil des mois des années que
la réalité de la politique de Vichy
c'est-à-dire sa systématique soumission
à celle de l'Allemagne se
révèle même parmi les résistants de la
première heure beaucoup croient encore
au maréchal
Pétin à l'intérieur de la résistance par
ailleurs vous avez des résistants
vichistes ce qui veut dire que ces
résistants ne considèrent pas
nécessairement de manière hostile le
régime de Vichy pense que certaines
réformes du régime de Vichy sont bonnes
sur le plan intérieur mais qui refusent
la collaboration c'est le cas dans un
mouvement de résistance que l'on appelle
l'organisation civile et militaire
d'individus comme Alfred Tuni ou Maxime
blockmascar en zone occupée où le danger
est grand l'OCM une puissante structure
paramilitaire a vu le jour en 41 sous
l'impulsion de membres issus des
diverses mouvances d'extrême droite
d'avant-gerre
l'un de ses dirigeants est le colonel
Alfred Tuni héros de la Grande Guerre et
ancien responsable des Croix de Feu du
colonel de
laoc ces individus ne sont pas
nécessairement hostiles au régime de
Vichi mais ils n'ont pas véritablement
de lien avec le régime de Vichi ils
n'essayent pas d'utiliser l'appareil
d'État ils n'essayent pas nécessairement
d'avoir des contacts ils construisent
leur action et leur organisation à côté
du régime de hii ce qui est bien entendu
une grande différence qui les oppos au
colonel Groussard qui essaie de
subvertir lappille d'État le colonel
Tuni chef de l'organisation civile et
militaire qu'on appelait l'OCAM dès la
première ma première prise de contact
avec lui au printemps de l'année
1941 a affirmé tout de suite devant moi
pour qu'il n'y ait aucune espèce
d'équivoque entre nous qu'il avait le
plus profond respect et la plus grande
confiance pour la personne du mar Pétin
ça nous a pas empêché d'être tout de
suite de très bons amis leocm était
plutôt d'abord assez autoritaire on a
également dans l'OCM des débuts des
traces d'antisémitisme euh on a une
logique très technocratique également
dans l'OCM et au fil du temps et bien le
le discours de l'OCM se poit se gauchise
l'antisémitisme les traces
d'antisémitisme disparaissent et le
caractère autoritaire de l'OCM disparaît
également
suite à l'arrestation d'une partie de
ses chefs le colonel ti reprend la tête
de l'OCM transforme l'organisation en
profondeur et lui fait prendre une toute
autre dimension au cours de l'année
42 ses membres organisent des filières
d'évasion et cachent des
armes tuny dote également l'OCM d'un
réseau d'espionnage le réseau centuy et
ouvre sa structure à de nombreux
militants socialistes qui affluent en
masse
dans ce mouvement on retrouve désormais
des figures de la gauche comme Pierre
Brossolette c'est ce dernier qui met en
contact ti avec le colonel reméy
ensemble il conviennent de transmettre
les renseignements du réseau santuy à
Londres via la confrériie
Notre-Dame le réseau de l'hémissare de
la France Libre a considérablement
grandi il s'étend à toute la France
occupée et Remy a installé à Paris une
centrale en liaison radio avec
Londres de plus il établit des contacts
par avion avec
l'Angleterre les réseaux vont prendre de
plus en plus d'importance et ils
prennent de plus en plus d'importance
aussi parce que soulignons-le les
Britanniques ont peu d'hommes sur place
la France était considérée comme un pays
ami et donc les Britanniques n'avaient
pas mis le paquet pour installer des
réseaux de renseignement avant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale grâce aux moyens
fournis par les Britanniques
Marie-Madeleine Fourcade a brillamment
repris la tête d'alliance
ses agents une centaine en 41 seront
près de 3000 par la suite dans la
clandestinité elle se fait appeler
hérisson j'avais choisi cette bête parce
que je trouvais qu'elle avait une bonne
défense des bons piquants et que c'était
un emblème qui pourrait me porter chance
dans ce combat et C si drôle parce que
les Allemands au début entendant parler
de hériisson ont cru que j'étais d'abord
anglaise et que je m'appelais Mrs
Harrison alors il cherchait partout Mrs
Harrison en réalité c'était le hérisson
qui recherché qui était bien roulé dans
un coup avec des
piquants devenu des pièces maîtresses
des services secrets anglais et golistes
Alliance et la confrirerie NotreDame
renseignent sur les capacités
industrielles et stratégiques des
nazis il procure aux alliés les plans
des installations portuaires fournissent
des informations sur les déplacements et
les positions des sous-marins
qui seront décisifs dans la bataille de
l'Atlantique ce qui intéresse également
les Britanniques ce sont des
renseignements d'ordre politique dans la
mesure où même si Winston Churchil ne
nourrit pas beaucoup d'illusion sur le
maréchal Pétin et bien il a encore
peut-être l'espoir que la France de
Vichy rejoindra le camp
allié en Afrique du Nord en 42 la grande
masse des Français et l'armée vichiste
reste fidèle à
Pétin mais les Anglais et leur nouvellel
alliés américain entrés en guerre en
décembre 41 ont besoin de prendre pied
en
Méditerranée il prépare alors une
opération de débarquement dans la ville
d'Alger baptisé opération torche en
liaison avec des résistants sur
[Musique]
place comme à Londres en 1940 où il y a
une surreprésentation des Juifs une
surreprésentation de l'extrême droite
c'est la même chose pour la préparation
du débarquement vous savez que les
Américains préparant le débarquement en
Algérie demande à la Résistance
française faites quelque chose pour nous
faciliter le débarquement parce que à
l'époque on sait toujours pas comment
l'armée française d'Algérie va réagir et
donc euh euh là se crée une alliance
entre d'un côté le groupe des ce qu'on
appelait le groupe des CIN qui sont pour
la plupart des des des gens d'extrême
droite des Français d'extrême droite euh
certains même euh assez antisémite
virulent et d'autre part les Juifs parce
que on a besoin d'hommes pour l'idée
c'est avant le débarquement il faut
s'emparer de la Poste faut s'emparer de
la gare faut s'emparer des téléphones
faut s'emparer de plusieurs points
stratégiques pour faciliter le le
débarquement américain or où va-t-on
trouver des gens sûrs des gens qui qui
ne ne nous dénonceront pas des gens qui
feront le travail sur les
Juifs ce groupe des CIN composé
notamment de colonel de l'armée
française mais aussi de dirigeants des
huiles lecieurs financiers de la cagoule
avant guerre stock des armes détermine
les lieux à occupé et manigance avec le
diplomate américain Robert
Murphy leur chef Henri dasastier de la
Vigerie ancien journaliste rêve de
rétablir la monarchie en installant au
pouvoir en Algérie le descendant de la
famille royale là était HRI d'Assier de
la Vigerie ancien monarchiste de 45 ans
qui avait certainement dans sa jeunesse
au latin criit plusieurs fois mort au
juifs et moi qui avait 22 gens qui étai
juifs et et qui avait quant à mes
sentiments vis-à-vis d'un homme comme
lui tout autant à son service qu'il en
avait pour moi et nécessairement on
s'est rencontré ça s'est passé à l'hôtel
Saint-Georges et bien on s'est très bien
entendu parce que la la force du
patriotisme ce sentiment maintenant
oublié était quelque chose de
considérable que vous que vous avez
beaucoup de mal à imaginer
ces hommes permettent aux alliés de
débarquer à Alger le 8 novembre 42 après
quelques heures avec l'armée vichiste
les troupes anglo-américaines s'emparent
de la ville et s'établissent en Afrique
du
Nord ce qui est décisif c'est que Darlan
l'amiral d'Arlan est à ALG il est plus
Premier ministre mais il il est le chef
des forces armées françaises Darlan
après un combat qui qui va être un
combat assez bref donne l'ORD au trou
français de le combat et ser RA lié aux
Américains et donc c'est Darlan qui
devient le chef de l'Afrique du Nord
Darlan promoteur de la collaboration
avec l'Allemagne arrêté par les
conspirateurs d'Alger et libéré par les
Américains il retourne sa veste et se
met à leur
[Musique]
soldes les résistants de toutes part
sont troublés Henri Dastier de la
Vigerie s'entretient sur place avec le
comte de Paris qui n'est autre que le
prétendant au trône de France Dastier
espère faire jouer au compte le rôle
entre les gaistes et l'armée d'Afrique
qui reste
pééniste dans la ville blanche des
complots se
tram Darlan qui a cristallisé les
oppositions est assassiné le 24 décembre
par un jeune résistant royaliste fusillé
peu de temps après sans que la lumière
ne soit vraiment faite sur les
instigateurs du complot Darlan est mort
mais la monarchie ne sera pas rétabli le
comte de Paris s'est rendu malgré lui
suspect de l'assassinat de
l'amiral les Américains désignent alors
le général girud arrivé clandestinement
à Alger grâce à un sous-marin affraité
par le réseau Alliance pour succéder à
Darlan Girot évadé d'une forteresse
allemande jouit d'une forte réputation
parmi les éléments les plus
réactionnaires de l'armée vichiste girud
a servi à ce moment-là lui qui était un
prisonnier évadé qui était un général
prestigieux qui choisissait le camp de
la dissidence et qui était mis en avant
par les Américains qui se méfiaent eux
de Charles de Gaul ne l'oublions jamais
hein Roosevelt se méfie de Gaulle et
aime bien girud puis girud on le sent
bien manipulable donc il peut être plus
facilement disons le mot impantin entre
les mains des anglo-américains ben Giro
facilite incontestablement le passage à
la résistance de pas mal de péénistes
sincères et au fond ce général Girot
pour toute une partie de l'extrême
droite ou des milieux conservateurs et
bien représente un bon choix parce que
son patriotime ardent ne peut être remis
en cause il combat au côté des alliés et
dans le même temps il se refuse à rompre
véritablement avec le régime de Vichi la
législation par exemple antisémite du
régime de Vichi n'est pas immédiatement
abolie les parlementaires communistes
qui sont fermé dans la prison de maison
carré ne sont pas immédiatement libérés
et donc pour toute une partie des
vichistes qui pour aller vite aime la
politique intérieure du marchel Pétin
mais déteste la collaboration Girot fait
figure euh
d'hommes de solution alternatives au
fond au
gaulisme décidé en réaction à
l'opération torche l'invasion de la zone
libre par la Vermar à la fin de l'année
42 sonne le glas de la fiction d'un
régime de Vichy souverain et radicalise
les
engagements nombre d'officiers
nationalistes de l'armée qui n'ont
jamais véritablement acceptter la
défaite se rallé alors à Girot et
rejoignne au cours de l'année 43
plusieurs maqu
des cadres de l'armée comme le
lieutenant valallet d'Osia organise la
résistance en formant des civils des
républicains espagnols des communistes
au maniement des armes et leur prodigue
un entraînement
militaire il est clair que certains
militaires de carrière ont pu jouer un
rôle important en épaulant les maquis
tout simplement parce que beaucoup de
maquis n'avaient pas d'instructeur
n'avaiit pas de professionnel de la
guerre voire en créant un C un nombre de
maquis lorsque l'on pense par exemple au
maquis d'oglière dans les Alpes et bien
on voit bien que la présence de militair
de carrière a été un élément très
important comme la présence par exemple
de valallette d'Osia donc ces militaires
vont essayer d'organiser au fond des
unités clandestines qui devrai se
découvrir au lendemain du débarquement
allié ce qui ici a été un échec mais ils
ont pu jouer un rôle important dans
l'aide voire la Constitution d'un
certain nombre de
maquis l'ancien chef des croix-defeu le
colonel de laaroc a pris la tête d'un
réseau de renseignement dès le retour de
la V au
pouvoir pourtant il reste obstinément
fidèle à l'égard de la personne du
maréchal Pétin alors qu'il n'approuve ni
la collaboration ni les mesures les plus
extrêmes de la Révolution nationale
comme les lois
antisémites malgré l'invasion de la zone
Sud laaroc reste naïvement convaincu
qu'il peut faire basculer le héros de
Verdin dans la guerre
début mars 43 il obtient difficilement
des rendez-vous auprès de
Pétin 48 he après sa dernière entrevue
laroc puis une centaine de cadres de son
parti sont arrêtés par la guestapo dans
toute la
France abandonné par le maréchal il est
déporté par les
Allemands il ne reviendra qu'à la
libération extrêmement affaibli et
mourra peu de temps
après hiver 43 l'armée allemande est en
déroute à stalingrade l'espoir change de
camp et de nouveaux engagements se font
jour parmi de nombreux Français désireux
de se battre les armes à la
main à partir du moment où la résistance
devient un phénomène de masse ou de
masse relative le poids des de l'extrême
droite baisse et le poids des Juifs
baisse là ce sont des masses de de
français auparavant non concernés par
exemple les jeune qui fuit le le service
du travail obligatoire à partir de 42
43 c'est des gens qui voit la victoire
approcher
aussi lorsqu'en février 43 le STO
service du travail obligatoire est
instauré les maquis et les mouvements de
résistance sont confrontés à l'afflux de
jeunes
réfractaires dans ces dernières années
de guerre ces jeunes se politisent à
gauche voire à l'extrême gauche la
problématique devient problématique de
cohabitation entre les communistes et
les autres les Gaulistes et les autres
vous voyez ce que je dire elle devient
une une problématique qui anticipe d'un
an ou de 2 ans sur ce que sera la vie
politique française après après après la
Libération en exzone libre désormais
occupé par les Allemands les mouvements
prennent une importance considérable au
sein de la résistance qui s'unifie
difficilement au cours de cette année
43 ces mouvements de résistance sont
différents des réseaux d'espionnage
grâce au distribution de tract et à la
diffusion de leurs journaux clandestins
ils ont une vocation beaucoup plus
politique et s'adresse directement une
population de plus en plus hostile au
régime de
Vichy il y aura trois grands mouvements
en zone sud le plus grand sera combat
l'unification de plusieurs groupes qui
vont fédérer dans Combat l'autre
mouvement sera libération et le trème
mouvement sera Fran tireur si vous
prenez combat et vous prenez les
personnalités importantes de combat
beaucoup viennent de la démocratie
chrétienne et beaucoup viennent aussi de
l'extrême droite j'ai mentionné Jacques
Renouvin il y en a d'autres pierre de
benauville en 1940 pierre de benouville
le bagareur de l'Action française qui a
rompu avec le mouvement au lendemain des
manifestations du 6 février 34 s'est
évadé d'Allemagne où il était retenu
comme prisonnier de
guerre
en décembre 42 il rencontre le chef du
mouvement Combat Henry fret entre dans
son mouvement et s'installe à Lyon
devenu le centre névralgique de la
résistance j'ai rallé Henri fr il m'a
donné mission de créer le service
national extérieur de la résistance ce
que j'ai
fait quand
fre a étendu les services que pouvit
rendre service à l'ensemble des
mouvements de résistance j'ai continué à
le diriger puis quand freenet est parti
pour Londres il a été remplacé par
Claude Bourdet et par moi au comité
directeur des mouvements Unis de
résistance et c'est ainsi que ce sont
passé ces
années autre figure du mouvement Combat
Jacques Renouvin avocat ultra royaliste
connu pour avoir défendu devant la
justice les hémetiers du 6 février
constiue les corps francs exclusivement
réservés à l'action la plus
dure ces hommes procèdent à des coups de
main font desrailler des trains
commettent des attentats simultanés dans
plusieurs villes de France visant les
officines de la collaboration exécuteent
les Allemands et les
collaborateurs les Kermes comme Renouvin
les appels doit faire régner un
sentiment d'insécurité pour les
partisans les plus Alés du maréchal ou
des Allemands véritable menur d'homme
Renouvin mê dans ses rangs les éléments
les plus extrêmes de droite comme de
gauche homme de contact benouville met
quant à lui en relation combat avec
l'OSS les services secrets américains
ancêtre de la CIA qui finance le
mouvement homme d'organisation il aide
un de ses amis qui vient de quitter
l'administration vichiste à monter son
réseau de renseignement cet ami c'est un
certain François
mitéran homme d'action il rejoint le
front italien à la tête d'une compagnie
de tirailleurs marocain et entre dans
Rome libéré le 4 juin
44 la victoire approche suite au
débarquement allié en Normandie la
France se libère peu à
[Musique]
peu le 26 août 44 de Gaulle descend
triomphalement les
Champs-Élysées grâce à l'unification de
la résistance il imposé un an plus tôt
face à Giro et aux
Américains la résistance unifiée qui
comprend les mouvements mais aussi les
anciens partis politique et les
syndicats d'avant-gerre UVR pour une
rénovation sociale de la
France la carte politique de la France
n'a pas été strictement réparti dans la
dans la Résistance tu admettras que la
résistance avait un cœur qui battait à
gauche soyons très modestes enfin un
cœur qui battait à gauche avec beaucoup
de gens qui venaient de ce qu'on
appelait l'extrême droite Jacques renouv
tu parlais de l'action immédiate tout à
l'heure jacqu qui a fondé les Corf
nationaux et qui est mort en déportation
il était royaliste n'est-ce pas et Jie
qui commandait les corfc à Toulouse
aussi et tout ça était mêlé avec de
gliam qui était communiste on peut
souligner que la résistance c'est dans
une large mesure gauchisée au fil du
temps alors la gauchisation de la
résistance vient de plusieurs éléments
le premier élément c'est que quand même
d'abord et avant tout Vichy est de
droite voire d'extrême droite alors cela
paraît évident de le dire aujourd'hui
mais en 1940 cela n'était pas évident
deuxème raison l'hégémonie communiste
c'est-à-dire que sur le plan
intellectuel le Parti communiste impose
son image il aurait été le grand parti
structurant de la
résistance évidemment l'extrême droite
est rabattu indexcè sur Charles Moras il
va adopter une attitude
absolument étrange et qu'on jugera à
juste titre comme étant absolument
scandaleuse pendant pendant la guerre il
sera pas collaborationniste il sera
jamais pro allemand mais d'un autre côté
il va continuer à développer ses idées
en attaquant les juifs et les résistant
donc c'est une attitude qui va conduire
un certain nombre de morassiens à se
désolidariser de de Moras et à quitter
le à quitter le moracisme plusieurs
intellectuels étaient à l'extrême droite
en 3940 comme claud Roy ou le futur
Chris Marker et ils étaient compagnon de
Dr du Parti communiste ou comme claud
droit membre du Parti communiste en 44
donc à quel moment est-ce qu'on situe
leur identité après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale on ne peut pas dire qu'il y ait
eu une survivance des résistants
d'extrême droite en tant que tel je
crois que vous avez plusieurs
itinéraires le premier itinéraire c'est
que une partie de cette extrême droite
et bien va euh succomber au charme du
gaulisme euh il est intéressant de voir
par exemple qu'un colonel réi qu'une
Marie- Madeleine Fourcade vont devenir
des piliers du
gaulisme dans ce grand chamboulement de
l'histoire
la résistance a permis de rapprocher ce
qui paraissait devoir rester
étranger beaucoup d'entre eux comme
benouville délaissent après guerre leur
antisémitisme de jeunesse qui allaiit de
paire avec leur
nationalisme louono la revenu de l'enfer
de Mathausen livre dans ses mémoires des
témoignages accablants sur l'horreur du
génocide
hitlerrien Marie-Madeleine Fourcade
milite dans les années 60 à la Ligue
internationale contre l'antisémitisme et
s'investit dans la cause
israélienne certains
historiens vont considérer que leur rôle
est beaucoup plus un rôle éducatif qu'un
rôle d'historien et on va essayer de
tracer deux rails comme si ces deux
railles étaient restés droit chacun
était resté droit la gauche antifasciste
bon S sont antifascistes sont forcément
résistant il se sont résistants ils sont
bien la droite a été fasciste ou
fascisante ou sous du fascisme et donc
elle était forcément collaboratrice et
donc elle est forcément mauvaise et
pourtant ce qu'il y a de frappant c'est
combien en 1944 et
1945 combien les résistants
multiplient les images pour exprimer
qu'en fait dans la résistance il y a des
gens de droite et il y a des gens de
gauche il des gens d'extrême droite et G
d'extrême gauche et vous trouz une
multitude d'exemple je pense à Emmanuel
Dastier de la vierie qui dit que
maintenant dans la
Résistance verill et communard sont
réconciliés versaillis et communar c'est
une image superbe ça veut dire la droite
et la gauche sont réconciliés dans la
résistance c'est Aragon qui dit à claud
droit claud droit qui vient de l'extrême
droite et qui passe dans la qui passe
dans la Résistance communiste qui dit à
claudrooit l'important n'est pas d'où on
vient l'important est où on
va à la Libération Marie-Madeleine
Fourcade se consacre à la recherche de
ses compagnons déportés et agit
activement dans les milieux de ancien
résistant afin de perpétuer le souvenir
du réseau
Alliance hanté par l'puration et la
haine entre Français qui en a découlé
Remy scandalise les golistes en
défendant la mémoire du maréchal Pétin
exclu du parti goliste il devient
écrivain à succès scénariste et livre
une littérature prolifique sur l'action
de la
résistance Jacques Renouvin arrêté en
mars 43 péri au camp de mataousen moins
d'un an après
le chef de l'OCM Alfred Ti est pris par
les Allemands en février 44 et fusillé
peu de temps avant la
libération fait Compagnon de la
Libération Maurice duclo se trouve parmi
les accusés du procès de la cagoule qui
se tient en
48 condamné à une peine légère il
s'exile en Argentine où il rejoint comme
tant d'autres cagoulard une filière du
groupe
Loréal geor lon la ent sous la 4e
République une carrière de parlementaire
et meurt en 55 le jour de sa nomination
au grade de
général directeur du journal Jourde
France administrateur de la société
d'assaut benouville joue également un
rôle d'anrometteur parmi le personnel
politique de la 5e République homme de
droite il n'hésite pas à défendre le
passé résistant de son ami mitéran face
aux accusations porté par
l'opposition